well hi ladies
how's everybody
good how are you i'm good listen i'm
good and i'm honored i'm excited to be
with you guys today i really really am i
know you've probably had so many
interviews so much stuff since coming
back from tokyo that it's it's it's like
you i don't know if you're trying to
decompress or if you can't even
decompress yet first i'm going to start
with simone because
everyone knows you guys all had an
intense tokyo olympics um i feel like
though and correct me if i'm wrong that
it might have even brought you guys even
closer together that's how it looked
from the outside in is that true i think
so just because we had to quarantine a
little bit so at the beginning and
throughout the whole entire process all
we had was each other so that made us a
stronger team as well as team final kind
of having to switch out it was
it was quite a meet so yes i would say
yes
jade is it something that
like you can even explain to people or
is it one of those things like you just
have to be in our inner circle and um
you know you just kind of had to be
there
um
it's pretty hard to explain i just feel
like it all happened so fast and like
you kind of just yeah i had to be there
well america can't get enough of you
guys so i hope you know that and and
jordan you know that's one of the
reasons why we're getting this 35 city
tour
uh for you guys gold over america tour
um what kind of experience can fans
expect from this
there's going to be so much going on i
mean if you truly think about it it's
going to be like a humongous gymnastics
spectacular there's going to be led
lights there's going to be interactions
in different types of ways on like
social media and stuff so it's going to
be really fun there's going to be
dancing and gymnastics as well so it's
going to be a really enjoyable tour
yeah hey michaela is
can you ever explain to anybody what an
olympic experience is like i mean
you know i sit there and i think i look
at them and i'm like you know in my head
i'm like oh i can flip i can but no i
know i can't but can you ever explain to
anybody like what that experience is
like number one representing your
country and then be
like the elite of the elite level of an
app it's definitely crazy i mean it
didn't even like hit me until you know
we competed our first event which was
floor and simone came running over like
you're officially living like olympian
it's real it's real and i'm like oh my
gosh like it really is like we competed
we're olympians now so
um i mean obviously it kind of feels
just like any other meat but it's
obviously a lot more stressful and a lot
more nerve-wracking like when we had
podium training i was actually like oh
this is good we got this and then once i
got out there i was like okay this is a
lot worse than i thought it was gonna be
and you know we didn't get to have any
fans so i feel like you know i do really
well under pressure so it's definitely
just a lot a lot of emotions a different
experience for sure but there is nothing
like it i wish i could relive that
moment it was just the coolest
experience you could ever have so i'm
just so grateful for you know this
opportunity and for all the girls and
for simone helping me every step of the
way and being able to step in for vault
and just having her cheer me on it was
seriously so cool and
i know she you know had to sit up in the
stands and i wish she could have been
out there but um everything was just it
was a dream come true and it seriously
just it was amazing so were you kind of
like mother hen even before
yeah i feel like in a way yes because
i've been there i've done it um most of
us have been to worlds but in olympic
games uh michaela got to go to 2016 but
it's very different it's very stressful
and be on such a big stage after covet
and all that
i felt like they just needed a little
bit of guidance and to know they weren't
alone so grace is michaela right it's
like the same set of players but just at
a heightened level uh the olympic
experience
it's really nice to see them all again i
mean it's been a long time i love
watching their gymnastics improve along
with the rest of our team well i'm just
gonna give you guys flowers today
because um you deserve it so simone you
know we've thought of you as the goat
for a very very long time so what kind
of advice
do you give to the rest of these girls
who now america has fallen in love with
and we're considering them the goats too
i would just say be smart especially on
social media because that can play a
huge role
for the rest of our careers but just
have fun capitalize on your success and
just go out there and
i mean you guys are olympic medalists so
it's awesome
i think that i um
i heard another word attached to you
throughout this whole experience besides
the goat and that was hero or heroin
um so now that you've come home and
you've had the chance to process
everything are you still very happy and
comfortable
with the decision that you made
yes i'm very content with my decision
obviously there's still a lot of feels
and emotions behind it but as far as my
olympic experience goes it was a very
unique and there was nothing like it we
even got to interact with the boys and i
i usually am not in the stands but i got
to be so i got to experience the
olympics in a different way and i
believe everything happens for a reason
so i wouldn't take it back for the world
um gave the girls so many opportunities
but
i'm content i mean i wasn't in the right
head space to compete so
i can't i can't be mad i did the safest
decision and it took a lot of courage
well let me go on the record and say i
am incredibly proud of you so very very
proud of you and support you one
thousand percent thank you but you know
we're entertainment tonight so we'd like
to talk about entertainment and miss
jordan you gained a new little celebrity
friend
throughout this whole
throughout this whole experience uh
normani i love that
yes i'm i'm still kind of in shock so
when i found out like everything how it
all started i woke up at four o'clock in
the morning tokyo time which is like
really really crazy
um and i thought i was just seeing
things in my dms and you know it said
normani and i was like i'm a little
confused like this is crazy
and she had messaged me and was like
congrats like you're doing so good and
then she like ended up following me and
then there's this whole long thing that
just went on it it's amazing i love her
so much like i'm still in shock
i i just like to see women supporting
women in that way like you didn't even
know her and she just wanted to reach
out and say add a girl i think that's
really really cool um you know simone we
saw that with you too i mean so many
celebrities supported your decision we
saw andy cohen carrie washington
michelle obama taylor swift everybody
coming out and saying no no no we've got
your bad girl we really do what does
that mean to you and did taylor really
make you cry
yes i mean it was just so sweet and so
special because obviously after pulling
out of the team final i didn't expect
that sort of support and love that i got
and it was very overwhelming and it was
just so sweet jade your dad is also your
coach so he was there by your side is he
gonna be with you on the go tour are we
gonna get to see him
no he won't be on the goat tour
but it will be like i feel like the
longest time i've ever been away from
him in my life
oh
we
listen who do we do we have to put out a
bat signal to get them like really can
this happen
it's okay michaela you know i do feel
like you know simone talked about you
got the um experience in 2016 and now
you did have this second chance um this
time what did that second chance mean
for you because i know it it probably
was like nerve-wracking and scary but
what did that second chance mean to you
um at the olympics yeah so you know
after 2016 being the alternate i was
kind of ready to be done in the elite
world so i wanted to go to college and
you know gymnastics was really hard when
we had marta and with everything that
went on so it was really nice to like
regain the love for the store and you
know i didn't i mean i kind of knew in
the back of my head that there would be
a chance for me maybe coming back and
trying for 2020 but it wasn't you know i
didn't really know it was gonna happen
and you know after
all the setbacks that i've had
throughout you know the last two years
trying to go for this olympics it's been
such a roller coaster being married and
having covet and pneumonia and kind of
having a little bit of a foot injury it
was just like you know like i really
wanted to make the team and knowing that
i was like i hope all this hard work
pays off and even being an alternate
last time just having that experience i
really want i really want to have that
again but to actually be out on the
floor and compete with the team so um it
was seriously
i just words can't even describe how
um how happy i am so it was definitely
worth it simone
you really are a a part of a growing
number of athletes especially who
have said we have to have this
conversation about mental health we have
to it's imperative for us um we've seen
just this week again naomi osaka getting
very emotional having to leave a press
conference um
have you connected with her have you
guys had a chance to just talk about
what you go through as a unit
sorry i'm trying to go to her text now
because she was actually really sweet
and she reached out and i actually i was
so overwhelmed so i didn't get the
chance to respond but i had so many
people reach out and she was just so
sweet i meant i saw what has happened
with her in previous times and she's
speaking up about mental health and i
think it's really important that
athletes in general put their mental
health first because at the end of the
day that's going to determine how well
we go out there and compete in whatever
sport that is and so i think now that
it's leading
topic of conversation is um really
helpful because at the end of the day we
are athletes it is our craft but we're
human too
[Music]